thanks to skillshare for keeping legal
eagle in the air learn to think like a
lawyer for free for two months by
clicking the link in the description
the dominant counter narrative against
the whistleblower complaint
is that it is hearsay and the critics
claim that the whistleblower complaint
is hearsay is
absolutely true in places it's actually
double hearsay
but this probably isn't the criticism
that you think it is
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because
certain american presidents and certain
republican senators from south carolina
seem to have forgotten how to do that
recently lindsey graham and many others
including the president of the united
states
are disputing the veracity of the
whistleblower complaint
and the readout transcript of the phone
call with the ukrainian president
on the basis of hearsay you can find
many prominent republicans going on
cable tv
and complaining that the whistleblower
complaint is hearsay and therefore
should be disregarded
the whistleblower wasn't on the call the
ig
inspector general didn't read the call
the president did nothing
in this phone call that's impeachable
you can also find them on twitter
basically recapitulating the same thing
that the whistleblower complaint and the
readout in the transcript
should be disregarded on the basis that
it's hearsay
lindsey graham has gone so far as to say
that you can't even get a parking ticket
in the united states
on the basis of hearsay and that's
somehow the basis for
potential impeachment of the president
of the united states
this seems to me like a political setup
it's
all a hearsay you can't get a parking
ticket conviction based on hearsay the
whistleblower
didn't hear the phone call recently the
white house has been scrambling to
counter the bombshell
allegations of the whistleblower
complaint and the ukraine transcript
as an aside when critics fight the
process instead of the substance of an
argument
it tells you a lot about the weaknesses
of their defense
you might have heard of damning with
faint praise well this is
praising with faint damnation well first
let's talk about the nature of hearsay
what is hearsay
hearsay is an out of court statement
offered to prove the truth of the matter
asserted in that particular statement
out of court just means it's not under
oath and not made in the particular
proceedings that are
occurring at the time and offered to
prove the truth of the matter asserted
is that you are relying
on the veracity of the statement itself
as opposed to some other reason so for
example let's say i testify in court
that will from knowing better said legal
eagle is the greatest youtube channel
that exists today
now if i were trying to prove the truth
of the matter asserted that legal eagle
is in fact the best
youtube channel out there then that
would be hearsay because i'm using the
truth of the matter asserted what does
that mean
basically whatever you want it to there
is no look
however if i am simply using that as
evidence to show that will has
seen legal eagle or that he knows how to
speak english
that's not using the truth of the matter
asserted in the statement and therefore
would not be considered hearsay despite
the fact that it is still evidence of
something that someone else
said outside of court also another thing
that trips up a lot of people is that
photos videos and audio recordings
themselves
are hearsay they are recordations of
statements that are made outside of
court so you need a hearsay exception if
you're going to admit
things like a video recording or an
audio recording into court
as you're probably aware hearsay is
often inadmissible in court but it's
often admissible as well it depends on
the rules of evidence and it depends on
the exceptions to the hearsay rule it
also depends on the tribunal
in fact my understanding is that in many
civil law countries hearsay is
always allowed and whether the evidence
is considered strong or weak
is left the trier of fact there's no
blanket rule that hearsay needs to be
excluded
but in the american judicial system and
the american tradition
hearsay generally is not admissible
because you can't cross-examine the
person who is making the statement
and you also can't check the credibility
of the person whose statement is being
elicited into court
basically it's a due process issue more
so than the common belief that hearsay
is just bad evidence and should not be
admitted
it's more about not being able to
cross-examine the declarant
on the contrary the rules of evidence in
almost every state and the federal rules
of evidence have
tons of exceptions where you allow
hearsay into
evidence american courts recognize that
like any kind of evidence hearsay can be
very strong or can be very weak it
depends on the circumstances
that's why generally you would look for
corroboration to the hearsay statement
or you would try and find counter
evidence to the hearsay statement as
well
there's absolutely no blanket rule that
says hearsay is necessarily
bad evidence and is not probative to the
issue at hand
you can imagine a circumstance where a
murder victim screams out oh my god mike
myers is killing me
right before mike myers kills them and
that would be pretty good evidence that
that person actually did the killing but
you might also imagine another
circumstance where someone simply just
makes up a statement that they claim
they hurt it depends on the particular
circumstance and you have to take these
hearsay statements case by case to
determine whether it itself is strong or
particularly weak it's sort of like the
difference between direct and
circumstantial evidence
often lay people say that circumstantial
evidence is
weak and direct evidence is very strong
where in
actuality in the court sometimes direct
evidence like eyewitness testimony is
actually
very weak because people have false
memories they don't remember things
particularly well
direct evidence often in the form of
eyewitness testimony can be
extraordinarily weak on the contrary dna
evidence for example
is 100 circumstantial but dna evidence
can
often be the strongest evidence that's
out there so just as the difference
between direct and circumstantial
evidence depends on
the particular evidence at issue it can
be weak or strong
so too can hearsay be weak or strong
depending on the circumstances and
depending on the corroboration or lack
thereof
and as you're probably aware there are a
lot of exceptions to the hearsay rule in
fact the exceptions probably
swallow the rule itself it's actually
kind of hard for practitioners
not to be able to get hearsay evidence
into evidence
in court proceedings in the federal
rules of evidence you can find the
exceptions to the hearsay rule
in fre 801 803 and 804
some of these exceptions are called
non-hearsay for some reason so if it
falls into the particular exception
it's actually considered not hearsay i
don't know why that distinction exists
other hearsay exceptions actually rely
on the declarant being unavailable
but in any event if a hearsay statement
falls into one of these exceptions
then that hearsay statement is admitted
into court and the fact finder is able
to consider the evidence
whether it's strong or weak so since my
practice often involves the federal
rules of evidence
let's take a look at the most recent
allegations and pieces of evidence under
the rubric of the federal rules of
evidence
now president trump's incriminating
statements to the
ukrainian president zielinski are
probably admissible on their face as
binding in missions against him under
federal rule of evidence 801 d2
which are admissions by a party opponent
in this case a prosecutor would be able
to use the
statements made by a defendant or in
this case the president of the united
states
against them in fact federal rule of
evidence 801
is one of those sections that considers
something not hearsay
so statements by a party opponent are
actually not even considered hearsay in
the first instance and even if that
wasn't the case that donald trump was
not
a party to these proceedings potentially
impeachment proceedings
the statements would still be admissible
under the exception to the hearsay rule
804
b which is a statement against someone's
interests
the declaration against interest
exception stems from the idea that if
you say something that is against your
penal
interest odds are you're probably being
pretty accurate because
why else would you testify basically
against yourself
additionally the things that president
trump is accused of which includes
extortion
bribery and abusing the office of the
presidency for personal gain
would almost certainly be considered
legal acts legal acts
are things that occur using statements
that carry with them
their own kind of legal significance for
example if you thought about a written
contract well
those are just written words that are on
a page and as i said before
documents themselves are considered
hearsay but
a contract is not considered hearsay
because you're not using it for the
truth of matter asserted so much as
the legal act itself of forming a
contract and the things that president
trump has
allegedly done would consist of
words that form themselves into a legal
act like how else would you
commit the act of bribery extortion or
abuse of power
without using those words themselves so
in that particular circumstance
those legal acts would not themselves be
considered hearsay
apart from president trump's statements
himself the
readout or memorandum of the call
between president trump and president
zielenski
would probably be admissible under a
number of separate exceptions to the
hearsay rule
including 8031 the present sense
impression
8035 a recorded recollection 8036
a record of a regularly conducted
activity or 803.8 a record of a public
office
business and governmental records are
often admitted into court using one or
more of those exceptions
some of those exceptions require you to
show a certain chain of custody
but in this particular case the white
house released it directly and has
admitted the veracity
of the particular call so i'm not sure
that you would run into those particular
issues in this case
now when you have double or triple
hearsay like when someone says
he said that this other person said this
other thing you can admit that too but
you need exceptions for every level
so that takes us to the whistleblower
complaint itself which indeed
would be considered hearsay as any
document would be considered hearsay
and it contains hearsay in the form of
things that other people
said so in order to admit that into
court you would need to have an
exception for
both levels and here the firsthand
witnesses are probably conveying a
present sense impression
into a recorded recollection business
record or record of public office
so that covers those two levels and to
the extent that a witness is conveying
something that president trump said
to the whistleblower that's considered
triple hearsay but again so long as you
have exceptions for each level it would
indeed be admissible
here president trump's statements are
both legal acts and therefore not
hearsay
and admission by a party opponent again
a non-hearsay slash exception to the
hearsay rule
now you can correct me if i'm wrong but
i don't think anyone is disputing that
the whistleblower complaint would not be
as strong as the more primary pieces of
evidence that the whistleblower actually
relied on and as always
you would want to corroborate or
disprove the statements of the
whistleblower and in fact
one such piece of primary evidence is
the
transcript itself what's incredible here
is that the whistleblower complaint
is so close to the transcript it's not
100 accurate but it's damn close
so now that we have the readout of the
trump zelinski phone call
there's no reason to use the
whistleblower's secondhand account of
that phone call when we can just turn to
the readout itself
and if the verbatim transcript or the
audio tape of this particular phone call
ever comes out
we'd want to use that instead of the
readout so it's absolutely true that the
whistleblower complaint contains hearsay
and double hearsay it's all the more
reason to talk to the intelligence
community inspector general
who did an investigation following up on
the whistleblower complaint
or the firsthand witnesses that
witnessed president trump and president
zielenski either
have the conversation or witnessed other
people cover
up that conversation and it's all the
more reason to examine the documents
that were generated as a result of this
conversation and others and that were
potentially hidden in a codeword secured
database away from everyone else so it's
odd and perhaps a little disingenuous to
focus on the hearsay nature of a
whistleblower complaint
when we already have evidence in the
form of the
transcript of the call itself that
corroborates some of the allegations
in the whistleblower complaint so the
whistleblower complaint is hearsay
argument
is probably not as strong as lindsey
graham thinks it is
and it's absolutely encoded in the
context of the actual primary evidence
like the transcript when the underlying
evidence is out
focusing on the complaint is a little
bit like the wizard of oz saying don't
pay attention to the man behind the
curtain
oh and by the way even if hearsay
weren't admissible in court which
it often is hearsay is used all of the
time in front of grand juries to seek an
indictment now impeachment is not the
same as a regular criminal indictment
we'll talk about that in a second
but notwithstanding prosecutors get
indictments using hearsay all the time
they're not bound by those same rules of
evidence
but even if we were going to talk about
the rules by which the senate will
conduct
an impeachment trial the senate rules
allow for the use of hearsay in an
impeachment
it even went to the supreme court in
nixon versus the united states in 1993
that's
not president nixon but a judge named
walter nixon and as you might recall
since history repeats itself
the last presidential impeachment was
started by one of the most famous
examples of hearsay in modern times
linda tripp secretly recorded her
conversations with monica lewinsky as
she talked about her affair with
president clinton
that was hearsay as well so critics are
right
that the whistleblower complaint and
some of the evidence contained therein
is considered hearsay it's just not the
defense that they think it is
now if you want to learn how to make
good arguments or at least better
arguments than lindsey graham
you'll probably want to brush up on your
public speaking skills i'd recommend
simon sinek's skillshare class
presentation essentials how to share
ideas that inspire action it's a
fantastic class from one of the world's
great public speakers about
making your next presentation
unforgettable sonec helps you banish
fears
of public speaking and learn how to
deliver effective oral presentations
45 000 students have taken the course
already and learned how to speak with
conviction
master public speaking transform nerves
into natural energy
and articulate what you really need to
say in a public speech
skillshare is an online learning
community that has tens of thousands of
classes on everything like
music design technology and business a
yearly membership is less than ten
dollars per month but legal eagles will
get two free months of skillshare when
you click on the link below
plus it really helps out the channel the
free premium membership gives you
unlimited access to must-know topics so
you can improve your skills and learn
new things
all free for two months so improve
yourself now so you can start making
non-hearsay arguments do you agree with
my analysis leave your objections
in the comments and check out my other
real law reviews over here
where i will see you in court allegedly